hi everyone my name is nishan saksina
and i'm the product manager for protein
purification portfolio
at gen script ink usa today i'll be
talking about
novel solutions for high throughput
antibody and protein purification
using the magnetic beads platform
the following are the contents of the
presentation so i will basically be
discussing about the current tools which
are available in the market and which
has been used by a lot of customers
and the need that is basically uh seen
for developing the mag sa plus protein
antibody purification system
i'll be talking about the mac plus
protein antibody purification system
itself
then i'll be talking about the menu that
we have for magnetic beads for purifying
the antibodies then followed by the
magnetic beads that we have
for attack protein purification and
finally i'll be talking about the
solutions that is provided by gen script
to reduce the culture volume from
several letters
to a 50 ml tube so that you can still
process your samples inside the mag
asset system
now these are the current tools which
are available in the market and you can
see that
there is a variety of tools that
customers use
for their purification needs and it can
range from
from a very simple and very inexpensive
method of gravity column
to a very expensive method like
automated liquid handling
platforms now you see that the sample
throughput
is pretty variable for all the systems
it can range from 10 samples
to 96 samples now the time that is also
required for processing these samples is
pretty variable
and it can range from three hours to a
maximum
of up to eight hours so uh also
the these systems they come with their
own advantages and disadvantages
so if we talk about these three systems
the the chromatography system the liquid
handling platforms
and the extraction instruments we see
that almost all of them
they have a pretty tedious process of
preparing the samples
because all of them they involve the
centrifugation step
they involve the filtration step also
they
involve the concentration step which
takes a
really long amount of considerable
amount of time
so if you see that you know the price of
the instruments
also is pretty high so if you see the
range of the price they range from
anywhere between 80k
to a maximum of up to 200k also
the gravity columns they are inexpensive
but they have other disadvantages like
there is too much labor which is
involved
it has low throughput and it has a very
low efficiency
now keeping this picture in mind the
amgen and
jet strip they came up with this idea of
coming up with
a new system which is based on magnetic
beats
and which can uh purify your samples
very fast without compromising the
throughput
and uh without compromising the quality
of of purity that you get after
finishing your purification
so uh the magnetic beads technology
actually is not new and it has been
known for many years
and it has been recognized as a very
cost effective way and an efficient way
for uh purification purifying proteins
and antibodies
now uh now and amgen and genscript they
came up with this idea of developing
this instrument
and uh they put this uh into a concept
where we have this mag sa
instrument and a magsay plus instrument
where you it's
a walk away instrument where you just
purify your samples
in minutes rather than hours so here
is the concept of the the purification
it's pretty simple
so once you finish culturing your
samples you just add the magnetic beads
to your sample
your magnetic beads will capture your
proteins or antibody of interest
and once that step is complete the
automated
instrument our mag sa plus instrument is
basically going to come
into picture where it's going to perform
all the washing and elution steps for
you
and once that elution and wash tap is
complete your purified protein or
antibody of interest
is going to be ready for use so it's as
simple as that
so there is no centrifugation no
filtration involved in this whole
process
there is no chromatography system
because this is a different system this
is a based on magnetic beads
there is no column packing because there
is no columns involved
it's a very easy to use instrument and
pretty automated system where you just
set up the protocol and walk away
it has a higher throat put because it
can process up to 12 samples at a time
12 50 ml samples at a time and up to 60
samples in a day
now let me talk uh to you about our mag
sa plus purification system
its capabilities and its key features
so uh the whole idea of developing the
mag sa and the sa plus system was
basically to shorten your purification
time
and that time basically is involved
in several steps which actually is
involved when you are using the column
based system
now when you are using a column based
system you are using uh
you are using centrifugation you are
using filtration
that takes a considerable amount of time
but now when you are using the mag s8
plus system which is based on magnetic
beads
you completely eliminate those steps now
that saves you a lot of time
and then saves you a lot of labor and
that is the whole
idea of developing the mag sa plus the
entire system is closed to minimize the
endotoxin contamination so in case if
you're
purifying your antibodies you don't have
to worry because the entire system is
closed and we have a function
built in the system to basically
minimize uh the
endotoxin levels and i'll be talking
about that in the coming slide
we have uh complete washing and elusion
steps which is performed automatically
so you just come set up the protocol and
walk away and your instrument is going
to take
care of the rest the system is capable
of purifying up to 12 samples at a time
the sample volume can range anywhere
between 2 ml to 50 ml
and it can process up to 80 milligrams
of antibody or protein per sample
now these calculations is basically
based on two of our
uh magnetic beads our amac protein a
beads
and our nickel charge beeps now both
these beads have a binding capacity of
about 40 milligram per ml
and the maximum amount of beads that you
can process inside the mag assay system
is 2 ml that is 2 ml saddle beats
so if you just multiply 40 times 2 it
comes to a figure of 80 milligram
and that's the reason we reach this
conclusion that we you can process up to
18 grams of antibody
or protein per sample in the instrument
the typical cycle time for 12 samples is
anywhere between 45 to 48 minutes
the instrument is very programmable and
very accommodating it's like a big
ipad where you can just touch the screen
and set up the protocol
and the minimum illusion volume that you
can get using the system
is 400 microliters so and that too in a
50 ml
tube so even if you have hard to express
proteins
you can elute it with a very small
volume
up to 400 microliters which is going to
give you a very concentrated
protein
it has a very user friendly software as
i just said it has a very
big touch screen and these touch screens
can be seen here these three all these
three are the touch screens
it has various interface like
pre-treatment tab uh processing tab and
strip stripping tab
now pre-treatment tab is basically uh
used for
uh pre-treating your instrument with
naoh in case if you want to reduce the
endotoxin levels
we also have the uv lamp so you can just
start this and it is going to
sterilize the chamber where you are
planning to process your samples
also the processing tab is the main
center where you process all your
samples
you just have to tell the instrument how
much magnetic beads you are using
for that particular run and you have to
select the correct ports
and the number of cycles that you want
to use for that particular run
once you tell everything you just click
on the start button
and a buffer usage amount reminder
screen is going to pop up which is going
to tell you
that this is the amount of buffers
that's going to be required for that
complete cycle
once you go back and check that you have
enough buffer uh
in your bottles you just hit start and
after that the instrument is going to
take care of the rest
the stripping protocol is also uh
included in the instrument so
since our beads actually can be reused
so there's a stripping protocol which is
also used in the system
so the instrument basically can
generate regenerate the beats for you
can just prepare the beats for you again
once you finish purifying your samples
uh using uh those speeds so you just
purify those beats and then you can
reuse them again
there's a usb software uh which is a usb
basically port which is present on the
instrument
that is for updating the software and
that is used for transferring the
protocols
to your computer please note that you
cannot uh attach the computer
to this mag sa plus system because the
mag s8 plus system is self-sufficient
you can save up to 50 protocols on the
system and you can recall them
at any point whenever you plan to use
them next
now this is a slide that basically tells
you about the fast workflow for antibody
purification
and it just compares the traditional way
of purifying your antibodies
and if you and compare the way
if you uh purify your antibodies using
the mag sa plus system
so using the traditional system you see
that you have to still centrifuge and
filter your samples perform
uh column packing then do sample loading
washing elution and then finally
followed by regeneration of your resin
in the case of mag sa plus it's a pretty
simple and straightforward process
once you finish incubating your samples
with the beads
you just bring it to the instrument and
the instrument is going to perform the
wash and the elution steps and the
entire cycle is going to be completed
in 45 to 48 minutes
this is a similar slide that actually
talks about the workflow of that protein
purification
so again comparing the traditional and
the mag sa
plus system here you see that in case if
you have the bacterial cells culture
you have to centrifuge your samples lies
your cells and once the lysis
is done you still have to centrifuge
them then filter them
and then finally you perform column
purification in the case of mbsa plus
you
still have to initially centrifuge and
lyse your cells
and once the lysis is complete you just
add magnetic beads to your samples
incubate them for the required amount of
time and once that incubation is
complete you just bring it to the
instrument
and the instrument is going to take care
of the rest
now this is a link that basically uh
tells you about the
the way the mag sa plus works
so let me just quickly show you how the
how the instrument is going to work
[Music]
so you can see that how easy it is for
you to basically uh
incubate your samples with magnetic
beads and then eliminate the need for
centrifugation and filtration steps
and then just purify your uh samples
using the mag sa system
now this is the typical setup for our
mag sa plus instrument and you see here
that on the left hand side you see the
mag sa
plus instrument and on the right hand
side of the instrument you see different
buffer bottles with different port
numbers written on them
now these port numbers they basically uh
tell you about the different buffers
that you are using
you they are also connected to different
tubings and all these tubings are
basically labeled with the same uh
port numbers that are written on the
bottle so
this port number you can see here it's
written here and the same port number is
written on the tubing as well
and these tubings are actually then
connected to the ports on the instrument
and these ports numbers are also labeled
with same
labels which are on the tubing and which
are on the bottles
so what you basically have to do is that
once you fill up these bottles with
different buffers
you just close the all the lids and then
put these this tubing on this on these
bottles and then you just connect this
tubing
to the instrument here on the ports and
once this is complete your instrument
basically
is uh it's all set up and ready to use
now you have a choice of up to five
buffers to use in the instrument so you
can
uh either use them for elution or you
can either use them for wash depending
on your needs
you have two buffers which is basically
for washing the nozzles and for wash
station
and you have one port which is for
dedicated to waste collection
now these are the features of the mag sa
plus instrument so here you see
that the number of samples that can be
processed at one time is 12.
it can it has a minimum elution volume
of 400 microliters so you can
elude using 400 microliters in a 50 ml
tube
the compatibility of the tubes is 50 ml
the number of buffers that can be used
in the purification is five
so it and again you can either use more
wash buffers or more elusion buffers
depending on your needs
the time required to process the samples
is anywhere between 45 to 48 minutes
the range of magnetic beads that you can
use inside the mag sa plus system
is 100 microliters to 2 ml satellites
that's the minimum
and maximum amount of beads that you can
use inside the system
the usb port is basically for updating
the software
and for transferring the protocol that
you have saved on the system
the reagent channels are seven and uh
these
uh there are several uh ports basically
which can be
interchanged and that's basically for
wash and elusion buffer
and you can save up to 50 protocols on
the system
now this is the data that basically
tells you about
the comparative analysis between mag sa
versus the chromatography system
and uh the recovery rate that we get
using different clones
of antibodies so here you can see that
uh the
the recovery rate is pretty similar with
both mcsa
and with the chromatography system but
what is difference
what what the difference is that there
is a lot of uh labor saving because
there is
uh and there's a lot of time saving
because you're not centrifuging
your samples and you are not filtering
your sample so if you're not filtering
your sample and if you're not
centrifuging your sample you are saving
a lot of labor
also you are saving a lot of money on
the labor
that you are paying that labor for
processing those samples
also the time itself for processing the
samples
is very little and that saves you a lot
of time so it's basically a win-win
situation
when you're using an mag assay system
versus a chromatography system
it's a similar slide that basically
compares uh the
antibody recovery rate uh between the
two systems between the mag assay system
and the automated liquid handling
platform
and here you see that with different
clones you again see that the recovery
rate is very very similar
and uh but what you save on is a lot of
time
and labor and money so a mag essay
it doesn't compromise on the quality you
still have the same recovery rate
but you actually save a lot of time and
you save a lot of labor when you're
using
the essay or sa class system
now these are the several uh mag essay
advantages
and these are the key steps which are
actually involved in the column based
system so here as you can see that there
are
the the thing the uh the these portions
which are actually written in black you
see
that these are the systems which is
basically different between the column
based system
and in the magnesis system so you have
to purge the system and fill it
buffer lines but in the case of mag
asset system you just have to
fill them uh with the buffer lines it's
pretty straightforward
you have to connect and equate the
columns in the case of column based
system whereas in the in this system
you just wash the beads and add them
directly to the samples
also you have to concentrate and load
the samples in the case of
a column based system but in the case of
magsa system
you just transfer the beads to 50 ml
conical tube
and that's it you are done with it the
the one that are actually highlighted in
red here
shows you the steps uh which are
involved
for uh processing 12 samples and uh
the number of hours that you will uh
require for purifying
uh the samples when you are using the
column based system
so here you see that uh the number of
for 12 samples
you need these number of hours for
processing these
these particular steps so when you add
them all it comes to a total of nine
also the when you're using a column
based system there is there are several
reagents that actually comes into
picture
you have to use several reagents like
disposable
filters and columns which comes at an
additional cost
so if you add up everything you see
that you know you are going to be
spending about 1200
to 3600 uh
dollars for processing 12 samples so you
can see that this is the cost that's
coming up with the column based system
now when you are when you are running an
mag s8 plus system
there are some costs which are still
there
like the like you still have to fill the
buffer lines you still have to wash the
beads and add them to the
samples you still have to collect and
elute the protein
and you still have to perform the
de-salting step but
the whole process is only two hours
so you see that the labor cost here is
only for two
hours as compared to nine hours in the
case of
the column based system also the reagent
cost is only for the magnetic beads so
it's only five
to fifty four dollars uh and then if you
see at the total number
for 12 samples you are looking at the
figure of 60
to 648 dollars for processing 12 samples
so you can see the difference in the
cost
how how major is the difference in the
cost if you are using
the column based system versus the magsa
plus system
now of course you uh do not com you have
a big advantage of uh uh processing your
samples in limited time
because you're processing your samples
just in 45 minutes
you have lower cost per sample because
our beads can be reused our beads uh
are can be reused up to 40 times for
protein a beads
and up to 100 times for our magnetical
beads
so if we are using our our reusable
beads you see that you have a huge
uh advantage of using them and cutting
the cost
even more oh also you have like several
hidden cost and time that are basically
time consuming
and those are the steps of
centrifugation filtration and
concentration
now why i'm talking about concentration
here it's because
our instrument can give you as little as
400 microliters in elution buffer so if
you're eluting with 400 microliters
your sample is going to be very very
concentrated and you do not have to
concentrate your samples
which you are generally performing in
case if you are using the column based
system
also the simplified and scalable it has
a simplified and scalable workflow
assuring a minimal training because
it's a very simple system and you can
and anybody can be trained
uh in just one go for the
mag sa plus system the purification of
microliters to litter sample volumes and
quantities so you can actually
use our magnetic wand or magnetic block
that i'll be talking about in my slides
and you can process like several
micrograms or several milligrams or even
up to
grams of samples using our magsa plus
system
so this is a summary of the uh the slide
so you can see that you can save time
that is 45 minutes you can save labor
that is no centrifugation and no column
filtration
and that is equal to your amazing plus
now let me talk to you about our dynamic
magnetic beads
portfolio so this is our menu for
antibody purification so you see here
that we have a variety of magnetic beads
that's available uh with genstrip so we
have protein a
uh we have protein g we have protein ag
protein
l and m mac protein a beads now let me
talk to you about mac protein
a beads which are the beads which can be
reused
and which has a binding capacity of
about 40 milligram per ml
they are base stable that means you can
just wash them with naoh and then
use them up to 40 times so that's the
best part about these beads
that you can just process them inside
the
instrument and then you can just reuse
them again
there are several other beads also which
are available which are mentioned here
and their binding capacities are listed
here
we also just recently introduced protein
l magnetic beads
and they have a binding capacity of
about 15 milligram per ml
of antibody or 5 milligram of per
ml of fab fragments
now uh let me talk to you about the data
that i have for our protein a magnetic
beads
so we just compare it with one of our
competitors
uh at the the response time of our
magnetic beads
so you see here that at zero seconds
both of them are suspended
but at six seconds you see that uh the
mag protein a beads they are all
attracted by the magnet but the one with
the
supplier b or with the competitor is
still in suspension
so you see that the response time of our
magnetic beads is really fast
now since our beads can be reused
several times we want to make sure
that they doesn't lose their binding
capacity with uh
when we keep on reusing them again and
again so we checked it them up to 40
cycles and what we found was
that there was uh no reduction in the
binding capacity of these beads
up till 40 cycles also we looked at the
uh the binding capacity of the beads
with the variable concentration of uh
uh antibody and what we found was that
the binding capacity of these b the
dynamic binding capacity of these beads
is pretty good as compared to the
competitor which
which is in the market right now
also since we are washing our beads with
naoh we want to make sure that there is
no protein
a leakage from the surface of the beets
and for that we perform this experiment
and we see that there is hardly any
protein leakage
from our beads we also compared the data
uh
for the purity and the endotoxin levels
if you are using the essay system and if
you are using the resin system and what
we found was that uh
using our essay system and using the
resin system there is hardly any
difference in the purity so using the
resin system
it's 98.10 and with the ss system it's
about 97.82 also if we talk about the
endotoxin levels there is hardly any
difference in the endotoxin levels
uh in the resin system and in the uh
system
so it's very very comparable
so uh mac beads uh for the tag protein
purification
are listed here so these are the this is
the menu that we have for the fat
proteins
we have nickel charge beads we have
magnetical magnetic beads we have
glutathione magnetic beads
we have streptavidin beads and we have
black magnetic beads now here i would
like to highlight our magnetical beads
which are basically
our beads which can be reused up to 100
times which are chelated resistant and
which has a binding capacity of about 10
milligram per mm
you can wash them with one molar naoh
and they can be reused
over 100 times uh we also have other
beads like nickel charge beads
glutathione beads uh streptavidin and
flag and their binding capacities are
mentioned here
now this is the performance of our
magnical beads if you see that you know
these beads actually they can be used uh
several times and
we just have to wash them with one molar
naoh and they can be reused up to 100
cycles
now this is the difference between our
nickel beads and our magnetical beads so
that of course their binding capacities
are different their application
is for magnical beads it's basically for
low expression of his stack proteins
or for samples which has high kilators
for the nickel charged magnetic beads
they are basically used for normal
hystac protein purification
a magnetical beads is uh having a
reagent compatibility of
up to 200 millimolar edta and 20 molar
molar dtt
in the case of nickel charged magnetic
beads it's only one millimolar edta
and ddt now the reusability of a
magnetical magnetic beads is over 100
times
but please note that is only in the
absence of chelators
if there is high concentration of
chelators in the samples you will be
able to reuse them
only five to six times but in case if
you do not have chelators you can reuse
them up to 100 times
for the case of a nickel charged
magnetic beads you can reuse them
four to five times but you cannot wash
them with naoh
you can just you purify the same protein
that you have purified first time
uh using these beads you cannot wash
them with any which
now these are the solutions that is
provided by gen script to reduce your
culture volume in case if you are
processing
500 ml or one liter or two liters of
culture
and if you want to reduce them to a 50
ml tube so that you can
process your samples inside the
magnesium system we have two solutions
available here
the first one is the magnetic one and
the second one is the amount magnetic
block
so these mag ones they are available in
two sizes they are available in large
and small size
and basically we have this magnetic rod
and
a sleeve and the sleeve can be washed
with naoh
what you basically have to do is that
whenever your cultures are ready
you put your magnetic beads there you
finish the incubation step
and once that incubation step is
complete you just insert the sleeve into
this magnetic rod
and then you just rotate it inside the
this um
your flask so that too to make sure to
capture all the beads
once you capture all the beads you just
take it out of the uh
of your flask and then you just take a
50 ml tube
with a small amount of a buffer you just
remove the magnetic rod and then you
just dip the sleeve
into the 50ml tube and all your beads
are going to fall
inside the 50ml tube and once that is
there in the 50ml tube you can process
that inside the magnessa plus system
the same goes for the mag magnetic block
you just can stick your block
at the bottom of your flask and then you
can remove all the liquid
you can replace the liquid with the
small amount of a buffer
and you can just transfer this into a
50ml tube
and once you have that in the 50ml tube
you can process that inside the
mag sa plus system that way you can
reduce your culture volume
from several letters to just 50 ml tube
and still use our automated
mac plus system
now this is the summary of the entire
presentation so the mag sa plus shorten
the purification time
uh it saves you a lot of time labor and
money
it purifies anywhere from 2 to 50 ml
samples and it can
process up to 12 samples at a time and
it can it takes anywhere between 45 to
48 minutes to process 12 samples
there is no proprietary buffers or
consumables that is required when you
are running the mag sa plus instrument
there we just provide you with the menu
they are all regular buffers and we can
provide the menu
uh if you need one from us there's a
variety of magnetic beads that's
available uh with genstrip
both for antibody and back protein
purification and protein a magnetic
beads are alkaline tolerant and they can
be washed
with 0.1 molar naoh and then they can be
reused
they can be reused up to 40 times they
have a binding capacity of about 40
milligram per ml
our ammonical magnetic beads are also
alkaline tolerant and they can
be washed with one molar naoh and they
can be reused up to
100 times they have a binding capacity
of about 10 milligram per ml
and they are resistant to kilators that
is uh to like edta and ddt there's a
there are several other chelators
but these are the ones that i have
mentioned but there there's a long list
of killers that they are
actually resistant to we have a variety
of solutions that is available to reduce
the volume
of your samples like one liter or
500 ml 250 ml like magnetic ones and
block that i just talked about and you
can process your samples in magsay
after reducing the size of your samples
thank you so much for your time and if
you have any questions please please
feel free
to email me to nish at nishanth.saksena
at jenstrip.com and in case if you are
interested in the demo
we are doing free demos of the
instrument we can bring it to your site
and we can give you free beats to
process your samples
and in case if you are interested in
that please
contact us at product genscript.com
thank you so much
you